[Music]
hey everybody welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainment I'm your host Walter
burn AZ ACK and today we are talking
about Justice League the flashpoint
paradox animated movie it's been a big
request from you guys for a long time
we're finally gonna cover it on the show
before we get into it as always want to
remind you guys like the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
new videos every single Thursday so go
ahead and check that out okay I'm the
panel today it's our huge our usual
people this is news you know we'll go
over to the left first miss Heather
Bruce what's up yes hello I'm excited I
always am I feel like every time I watch
the shows I say I'm excited every time
so sorry well I mean human interaction
is great all right and mr. Brian Porter
how's it going min sup yeah Anna wait
how's it going pal well I'm excited as
well oh that's awesome
well anyway yes Justice League the
flashpoint paradox is a 2013 DC animated
movie like I said before we're gonna try
to make our way through all these DC
animated movies so always leave
suggestions in the comments below about
which one you want us to cover next our
usual thing here is to go positive
negative so we'll go positive first what
do we like about the flashpoint paradox
Ayana would you like about this I like
seeing all that all the characters in it
like we get Aqualad in this and get in
the comics I always like seeing him
always like getting to see his weapons
they're super cool like Thomas Wayne
Batman super dark super awesome so I got
some like really cool characters that I
love seeing that we're in the comic that
weren't in it that we're kind of cool so
yeah overall your your into this one
yeah okay cool hi there would you like
about the flashpoint paradox um well I
had some similar things that I had
written down
Thomas Wayne Batman Tom Wayne Batman was
pretty fun yeah you know guns blazing
guns blazing
more okay with Thomas Wayne doing that I
mean it makes sense for his character
projects to position of the differences
between two bats being like this Bruce
Wayne mad right he drinks and shoots and
murder murder yeah yeah that's fine
minute while we're on the topic of the
Wayne's and the other universe so to
speak I loved to that they did that
little like Martha way and is the joke
just a little hint into that refers to
the Joker like a couple times we see the
Joker cards yeah right right right
um I really liked the inch of the
beginning fight in the introduction to
yeah I really liked that too are you
can't reduce the characters dead well
definitely it did a good job of bringing
in all the rest of the Justice League
but still starting with the focus on the
flash but it did a good job of bringing
in all the Justice League characters and
kind of having a quick introduction to
them without being like Batman Superman
the first the first one to come in with
Batman and crashes through the room yeah
yeah it's almost a way to see the team
ups different in the alternate timeline
well like here are the good guys here
are the bad guys and then so when we go
to this other like alternate like
universe and timeline that's basically
because you know people have been
rearranged in that timeline which is
really cool so they're not necessarily
good and evil they switch they all sort
of jumbled yeah yeah you don't know
what's going on with them to it's like
which is interesting
yeah they're working for the government
right yeah I was pretty good right
anything else that really stuck out to
you positive yeah I kind of I liked the
way I hear the way they set up the
premise of the other world like there
was a lot of exposition to get through
because obviously we've never been in
this world before I need to get through
a lot of that stuff but it was done in a
way that wasn't like punching you in the
face with like hey this is the way that
so-and-so is now right and not it was
just like spelling it out like you're
dumb as hell yeah right exactly all the
girls in dark lipstick right she's bad
oh she must be evil she wears black
lipstick yeah I agree
okay well or would you like about this
um I like the story overall I thought
was pretty good I liked how brutal it
was because that's kind of cool to see
and is she yeah it's very brutal and it
was like refreshing to see how brutal
these characters can be because you know
there's super-powered entities they can
do some damage and definitely it's shown
how pretty brutal they can be so I
really like that Thomas Wayne was really
good I liked uh reverse-flash a lot I
thought he was a cool character and I
really like see thomas Howell who voiced
him I really really really captured the
character so it was really fun in the
brutality vein there was that scene with
Diana is just getting tossed around like
a rag doll and that's like super
upsetting to like see I remember that
fight was like really interesting
because just some of the like when you
flip over a character to be someone else
you're still kind of rooting for them
because you know art there's still that
kid right at the same time but at the
same spirit different different people
that seems specifically was kind of cool
with being able to see like how brutal
she was being and then you're like oh
it's kind of just remember the first
time watching it being like oh god oh
god yeah okay here we go we're killing a
child okay they're good guys
here's Mary's head just right right oh
yeah there was blood there was gore
there was cursing they like they went
for it and they weren't like can you
give us an R and we'll see what we do
with it yeah in this you know I I'd
liked it more than I disliked it for
sure it's not one of my favorite DC
animated movies but the stuff that I
liked about it
I read the book and then immediately
watch the movie last night
so I've seen the movie before but I
hadn't read the book previous to this
and it's morph the movie in a weird way
is more fleshed out than the book I mean
I think they go at like one shots and
everything in the flashpoint universe
there I know there's like Hal Jordan
flashpoint and Batman flashpoint you
know miniseries or whatever but in the
main storyline here did there aren't a
lot of details like the whole thing with
Wonder Woman and Aquaman in the movie
like they show flashbacks they show that
whole build-up and I thought that was
really well done and showing like you're
talking about the Joker you know Martha
Wayne is the Joker that was really cool
but in yeah and the book is just like
like I loved you well you shouldn't kill
my wife and then they're just like a
little off hand things like that but the
movie I thought a lot of the back
stories handle actually better so that
was really cool and I did like the
Justice League adventure at the
beginning it was like a mini Justice
League episode kinda yeah so that was
really fun and I do like how I did deal
with more mature themes and very taking
responsibility for he this was all his
fault he found that at the end you know
spoilers there he actually traveled back
in time and this is kind of his fault
and like it's just one person who like
in any one significant I like this is a
good movie okay fine
yeah let's go let's go into negatives
now negative about the freaking
animation was absolutely awful sir
redness it was terrible this is the
start of the freaking down it's not the
same animation terrible in the Justice
League war this this is where the DC
went wrong and then continue down the
hill of of animation like I hate
this animation style justice lady awful
awful
what's the Bruce Timm gods and monsters
of monsters came after this that's great
news Tim when you first see the Superman
in the beginning face body like is so
disproportionate picture there you go it
made me want to throw up a humanoid
figure what is that that looks like
and Aquaman looked really weird and just
ladies and boxy and bulky but not in a
muscular way in a I'm a polygon type
shape polygon like it's just big big
head syndrome for DC ladies it's
terribly animation it was small weird
face down that's how I chose when I was
like a child no I did big head and tiny
little bodies people love this movie so
I know we're gonna get you think I
didn't I didn't mind the animation there
were parts like Superman I didn't like
some of the character models but overall
I watch a lot of anime so I don't know
if I'm more used to that style or what
it is but I didn't mind it as much it
wasn't even like that it wasn't like
full anime though it was just like kind
of anime the beginning where the opening
was like full-on anime
in my opinion really stuff like yeah I
could see that but I mean like sequences
I felt like we're very funny anime well
it was like CG you know like when he's
running in stuff I don't think yeah but
like yeah the first part it's not very
anime but I think certain parts but I
don't know I don't think it was like
full like hunter percent the consistency
with how they wanted to model their
characters I think there was there was
no consistency with it like Thomas Wayne
Batman looked pretty decent I like it
was proportionate good yes he did come
down his waist was like yes but I mean I
appreciate that they tried to make a
different style to differentiate it as
like the new 52 I understand maybe where
that's what we're trying to do I get it
fine but I don't feel like it was the
style so much as it was like some like
I'm gonna get some hate for this for
some like lazy animation like the
Superman in the beginning you could have
tweaked the style just this much and it
would have been a little mu Tiger body
I enjoyed sure sure I am a style
coloring I enjoyed it sure
and from from this movie on they they've
kept this kind of weird anime style and
it's just it's never the same it's
different than then if they can't
consistently recreate movie the movie
and then it's always different in these
character models always look like
half the time yeah it's not the same
thing as this though they they adjusted
it I mean it's not like this it's not
this kind of style in the in the DC
movie universe whatever
Jason Mayer Batman and all that but
don't get me started on that that's
another story but but yeah I mean I
think we all agree that maybe the
animation wasn't the best at some points
at least someone's yeah I mean the book
I do art in the book looks great why is
it such a novel concept to just transfer
the art from the book to the movie as
best you can okay like I know I
understand things I feel like a lot of
the times you just want to see the comic
literally voiced over on screen
sometimes and sometimes I think maybe
you can give the artist leeway to do
what they do right and it's a huge
difference to be an artist for a comic
book absolutely than it is to be an
animator sure that's what I say to a
certain degree but like I feel like you
should try to encapsulate as much of the
original content as possible like this
he's like Thomas Wayne's Batman suit is
so different and so badass and so you
that's from the comic and sure you know
we're gonna see that this one yes this
one did but like the rest of them like
it's like you know what I mean okay
the you we should try and mirror that as
much as possible you do your you know
changes whatever here and there subtly
add a little flare but like this huge
anime just departure from anything in
the comic just to look nice okay so
besides the animation styles or anything
you guys didn't like about this one
Heather I actually was not a huge fan of
the pacing of this mmm it got really act
then sometimes kind of I don't want to
say boring because it wasn't boring I
wasn't bored I feel like sometimes the
pacing was off like in between the
actions yeah in between the action
sequences and then it was a lot of just
action at the end like for a lot of
exposition we got in the middle it was
just like a lot of action the pacing
just kind of took me out of it every now
and then okay I pour anything else
besides the animation you know really I
thought it was pretty movie is pretty
solid movie like animation aside the
movie was pretty good like follow the
story the characters were good it made
sense you know it felt follow the
logical path of events like yeah really
good core for Barry I mean I think we've
seen this story handled better in the
flash TV show actually what to degree I
mean we've still got to see how it goes
we'll see how it goes right
I mean I mean like the the mom you know
dying thing like I think that like the
season one of the flash told a better
story than this did of that same kind of
calm yeah yeah maybe that's what I felt
like with the pacing at the beginning or
whatever I didn't feel an emotional
connection wasn't like I didn't feel
like it was enough for me to feel like
he needed to go back and change it yeah
well I feel I kind of feel the same way
in the flash TV show yeah we like did it
see it in the movie like we didn't see
it happen until the end because I
actually thought that while watching it
I thought it was weird I had to go back
and be like wait did we see it because I
forget
and so I I kind of like it we didn't
repeat it actually yeah and that would
they just picked one cuz I would have
been like unnecessary right oh it mean
it works on the the show but yeah we had
a whole season of
felt like I didn't connect as much in
the movie because we didn't see it at
first and we waited until the end to see
it so like it all came together but
maybe that's what they were going for
that right bring all the emotion up
right at the end that works sure is
there anything that you didn't like
besides some of the animation really not
particularly there was some like
timeline stuff that was that was weird
but that's sort of the nature of it
where it's weird that it changes like
past memories and then he starts you
having his memories collapse on himself
with any key i don't really it's a
little convoluted but i mean obviously
you're working with like that's gotta
happen but there were a few things that
were just a little off with that for me
but okay there than that no I thought it
was a pretty strong story great I mean I
do feel like the comics handle the
time-travel issues better yeah yeah I
agree I like the explanation
reverse-flash at the end is I think more
consistent and kind of cool but I like
when they just tweak with the characters
and alternate timelines because we know
these characters so well that it's so
interesting to see like Oh Batman isn't
evitable no matter who's killed in the
alley when they're killed these these
characters are always going to happen in
these ultimate not in universes but like
timelines they're always gonna happen
it's an inevitability so I really like
that and it man it talks about my how
much change yeah the ending with Thomas
giving or you know berry giving Bruce
Thomas's letter that was really good
it's really good in the book I think the
one thing that I remember from the comic
two years
[Music]
in terms of negatives for me besides the
animation stuff yeah I have a lot of
stuff about the animation but but yeah I
think that the the Batman stuff in the
book is also different than in the the
movie I mean like in the book I mean
he's gruff it's like the same character
but he's not using guns and drinking
alcohol all the time in the book they
just you know just shooting everybody up
and I mean it was cool for a bigger
contrast so I can get forgiven to some
degree there's a couple of lines in here
we're just freaking terrible and some
line readings were just bad I think some
of the the voice casting was very
strange I didn't really like Barry that
much there's a line I mean I can't
remember it might be towards the end or
something but there was a line where I
was like wow that was that was a really
bad line reading I couldn't believe they
left that in but um but yeah I mean it's
it's a house it's it's a it's a strong
animated movie it's a solid I can say
it's solid yes
but it didn't really draw me in as much
maybe because it's so much happening so
quickly but I like Heather I wasn't as
like attached to everything I was right
yeah for other DC animated movies that
were just like from the start like I get
it I'm on board this was like I should
be on board but I'm not I don't know
what's missing
but I don't know there's a sort of a
missing element that maybe they didn't
there wasn't enough subtlety in in
Barry's relationship with his mom or
something or maybe got thrown in too
quickly I don't know but something was
definitely missing for me but yeah all
right so let's move on to the next
subject here where does this rank for
you guys in terms of DC animated movies
it's right up there with my Batman films
right let's be real because those are
just so well done but it's it's up there
I'd say it's chopped middle because I
don't as much have a problem the
animation so it brings higher for me
because of that I like it's story wise
and it covers a lot of the Justice
League characters so it's higher for me
so I'd say it's top of the middle okay
in the middle - it's not my favorite but
it's also not the worst and I guess I
might put it just above first flight
okay okay all right
I'd say like like number ten in the top
ten like the only reason you put it in
downtown yeah that's just because the
story itself in the you know it was a
good solid movie okay I take away the
animation all that crap like it is it's
a solid movie I remember liking the
movie right so like I'd say like number
10 maybe not good so but yeah definitely
not near the it's in the top ten that's
in the top ten so there's a lot of
difference there's a lot you see
animated movies so there's really a lot
there's like a handful there's life I
could probably do like seven or eight
off that man okay
well that's why I said a handful so yeah
but well anyways yeah for me I'd say
it's just about like in the middle I
mean I enjoyed it enough to where I got
some enjoyment out of it but there's so
much better stuff out there yeah it kind
of it eclipses this by far in my opinion
but I know a lot of people like it so if
this is your favorite let us know in the
comments it probably already did so
that's cool just so yeah are we looking
forward to splashy's in 3d to come out
guys yeah you guys excited this night
that's why I want to cover this I
remember when the when the show first
came out we saw the pilot may have the
tag at the end with Barry missing and
this is madam like they can't do
flashpoint Paris there's no way they
could do flashpoint paradox they don't
ever do those characters yeah and I was
like they're doing the last point it's
like okay this is gonna be interesting
yeah it's gonna be I don't know I mean
like I've trust the flash but mm-hmm
that him running back in time at the end
of season 2 was so random you know I
don't know I mean
I just got my time replicant to kill
himself all this stuff no just gonna
screw all this stuff yeah and you'd
think that he would go he really like
had the Cathars I know I know with over
it yes fine thank you yeah yeah so why
not save Henry
you know what's gonna happen thing but
with Jay Garrick I'm a real Jay Garrick
I think he's gonna show up again in this
season right so we're all looking
forward to flash season 3 pic of the
week is flashpoint the original book by
Geoff Johns and ecoo Burt Sandra hope
the names on the front of this book here
it's different than the movie but it's
it's pretty accurate for the most part I
mean like there's there's actually more
detail in the movie like I was talking
about earlier right there yeah
definitely but they took out element
woman who I think I think an enchantress
was he's a big turncoat in this that
doesn't show up also Captain Thunder is
awesome in this although the marble he's
really cool in the book and in the movie
you get just a little bit and there's
actually a lot of motivation for him he
has like this big grudge against a
Wonder Woman because he like got scarred
by her for like no reason he's like
super pissed off so it's like really
angry Captain Thunder and I Captain
Marvel or Shazam
and this flashpoint universe but yeah
the book is it's cool it's interesting
it's not one of Jeff's John's best works
but it's still cool enough for I think
people would be into it so go ahead and
check that out
ok we'll go into social media really
quick where can we find you you can find
me on Twitter at Heather ruse or
Instagram a teachers fantastic Porter
facebook.com slash awesome Porter all
right Ayana
Twitter Facebook 1 Instagram well
someone snapchat now
me find her I am on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter talk to me about
whatever you want make sure to like the
Facebook page face it for the
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
come back next week because we're gonna
be reviewing season 1 of the next flick
show Luke Cage so come back for that
sweet Christmas for reviewing Luke Cage
alright so until next week these people
aren't they're pretty cool I mean I like
them watch I'm Walter Bernays yak and
we'll see you on the next page
[Applause]
you
[Music]